when we look back over the last century
of innovation in flight it's sometimes
hard to believe how far we have come
the Wright brothers first flight in 1903
was at best that proof of concept only
managing the flight 37 meters before
falling on gracefully from the sky we
often look back at this historic event
and see it as a spark that ignited a
century of human flight the truth is the
event barely registered in national
media and most questioned the legitimacy
of the news it took another three years
incremental improvement than public test
flights before the international
community began to accept their
achievements and by that stage others
had begun to catch up and even surpass
their designs by 1910 Louisville aru had
flown across the English Channel Jorge
Chavez soared over two kilometers to
clear the Alps and Glenn Curtis began
testing planes as a platform for weapons
at his biplane became the first to take
off from the deck of a ship this nice a
trend for the next 35 years of aviation
which was dominated by war and by the
time World War two came to a close giant
companies had been formed who were mass
producing planes capable of transporting
humans across the world these companies
were not going to simply vanish as the
war ended and instead set their sights
on building a new commercial civilian
transport industry in the final year of
World War Two over 4,000 Douglas dc-3s
had been built and many of these would
go on to be converted for civilian use
the dc-3 is still the most produced
airliner in history with over 16,000
built and some are even still in service
across the world but it's slowly being
caught up by the Boeing 737 which has
sold so many units that at any single
point there is an average of 2007 37th
and air
the 737 made its debut in 1968 and its
design has essentially become the
template for which most jet airliners
have been built on since the initial
design of the 737 had the engines
mounted on the tail
similar to the dc9 which the 737 was
competing with but placing the engines
here reduce the amount of space
available towards the rear of the cabin
and mounting the engine pods tight
against the underside of the wing freed
up space at the back of the cabin for
passengers which was important for this
narrow and short body short haul plane
it also reduced the bending load on the
wings counteracting the upward bending
load caused by the lift
the success of this design has allowed
the 737 to st. service for over half a
century with incremental improvements
and today it's so popular that most
budget airlines like Reiner and
Southwest used no other plane its
engines have got gradually larger and
more powerful its cabin got larger as
traffic increased winglets were
introduced to the wing to reduce induced
drag and later this year the latest
iteration of the 737 which has already
sold over three thousand four hundred
units will make its debut with new split
winglets more efficient engines an
improved flight deck and the modern
cabin interior developed for the 787
dreamliner this team of incremental
improvements in the airline industry
happens for a reason
introducing a totally new plane design
is an incredibly risky business we need
to look no further than the failed
concorde for proof of that but even
introducing a new plane series like
Boeing 787 can cause massive losses in
revenue the plane was plagued with
delays originally slated to arrive in
2008 but actually made its first
commercial flight in 2011 and only
recently had destroyed in manufacturing
and sales new designs are simply a risky
business decision and in general
companies will play it safe and not
break the mold on top of this the plane
service life is a huge part of its
selling point airlines want to buy
planes that maintain their value over
the years and can last him a significant
amount of time with minimal maintenance
so manufacturers have made effort to
increase the service life of these
planes which in turn has increased the
cycle times between new iterations of
planes making progress even slower again
with the current status quo of the
airline industry we aren't likely to see
much change anytime soon what of a new
industry disruptor emerged one that
could shake up the duopoly of Boeing and
Airbus to force competition and new
designs we have seen this happen in
other industries recently the energy
sector has been revolutionized by cheap
solar panels Tesla was the first
successful Kara startup in America for
over a century and compliment materials
are set to continue replacing metals in
many everyday applications these
disruptive technologies combined rising
air traffic could raise the pressure to
innovate in this new series of videos
I'm going to break down a number of
future aircraft and the design
challenges they need to overcome to
become a reality let's first take a look
at the da's nicknamed the double bubble
developed by Aurora MIT and with the
help of NASA the current template of
plane design at the moment consists of
Jubilees fuselage this shape is
primarily there to resist the internal
pressurization allowing the fuselage to
expand without creating dangerous stress
concentrations as long as we pressurize
the inside of our planes this design
aspect won't change but we can create
fuselages with multiple interconnecting
tubular sections this is exactly what
the d8 does with its double bubble's
fuselage so let's look at how they came
up with this design and the theory
behind their design choices to design
this concept they actually set it off
with a 737 and performed a morphing
study by gradually introducing their
design goals to the current design they
started by first optimizing the airframe
of the current 737-800 airframe with
current generation improvements they
then changed the fuselage to feature the
double bubble this shortened and widened
the fuselage considerably the wider body
and shake nose allows the body of the
aircraft to generate more lift
particularly at the nose this allowed
the wings to get Center and thus reduce
the drag they generate but it also meant
that the tail wing could decrease in
size to the primary purpose of the tail
wing is to generate downforce at the
rear of the plane which keeps the nose
of the plane up an important stability
characteristic but when the nose
generates its own lift the importance of
the tail wing is diminished and it can
decrease in size which again reduces the
drag
they then reduce the cruise speed of the
plane from 0.8 Mach to 0.76 which may
seem like a step backwards but remember
the primary goal of this future design
is to improve the efficiency
this allowed the wing sweep of the plane
to decrease if you don't understand this
go ahead and watch my wire plane windows
angled backwards video in the next
iteration they reduce the cruise speed
again to 0.72 essentially removing the
wing sweep altogether reducing the speed
of the plane reduces the thrust
requirements of the plane which reduces
the fuel consumption reducing the sweep
reduces the wing area which again
reduces the drag so reducing the speed
by just 10% results in a much larger
percentage of fuel savings considered
that if you are flying a three-hour
flight this would increase your flight
time by just 18 minutes and this
increased transit time would be even
less of an issue when you factor in the
reduced boarding times that the double
oil configuration facilitates the next
design iteration move the engines from
under the wing to the rear of the plane
and mounted the engines flush with the
fuselage but this requires some future
tech that isn't quite ready with the
current configuration engines are placed
far from the body of the plane and so
the air entering them is undisturbed in
uniform this is ideal for engine
designers because each of the blades and
the compressor experience the same air
pressure and speed through each cycle
but if we move the engines tie it
against the back of the plane the
engines have to ingest the boundary
layer airflow which is the slow-moving
layer of air that builds up on the
surface of the plane this type of engine
is called a boundary layer ingestion
engine and it has been a topic of great
interest for NASA and other aerospace
companies because it reduces the loss of
kinetic energy of the aircraft greatly
in a normal plane this boundary layer of
slow-moving air simply rolls off the
back of the plane and mixes with the
fast-moving air this causes vortices and
a low-pressure zone behind the plane
which creates drag the idea behind the
boundary layer ingesting engines is that
they take the slow-moving air and speed
it up and thus eliminate some of the
drag it's a nice idea that it's fair for
being ready the first problem we face is
that non-uniform air entering the
engines the air entering the engines
furthest from the fuselage of the plane
is moving faster than the air entering
from near the surface this creates a
discontinuity of stress as discussed
before in my dream liner video cycling
through high and low stresses is very
bad for any part as a result in fatigue
of the parish and when your part is
rotating true those high and low
stresses a few tells in times per minute
your part isn't going to last very long
and that's just problem number one the
next big problem is stalled air flow
normally moves the uniformly through a
jet engine but when it's distorted as it
enters the engine there's a high risk of
compressor store compressor stall works
similarly to stall on a wing where the
speed and angle of attack of the wing
can result in flow separation behind the
wing this prevents the wing from
generating lift and the stall occurs
non-uniform turbulent air makes it far
more likely to occur when this happens
in a compressor it can lead to a chain
reaction of stone as the localized
stagnated air travels with the blade
it's stalled on but lags behind slightly
allowing it to come in contact with
other blades which then stall to
compressor stall may just result in
localized areas of stalls that affect
the engine performance or it can result
in a complete flow reversal where the
incoming air is not being compressed
enough to work against the previously
compressed air which results in an
explosive flow reversal with air coming
out of the inlet of the engine for these
edit engines to ever make their way onto
a commercial aircraft significant leaps
an airflow prediction and engine design
and control will be needed although
there are technical challenges their use
could offer a significant reduction of
fuel consumption over the current
generation of potted engines all of
these technologies combined in the da's
have been calculated to have a potential
fuel savings of nearly 50% over
conventional technology and with the
continual rise of fuel flights this
plane could be making its way to an
airport near you sooner than you may
take thanks for watching this episode
was made possible by Squarespace they've
helped me make my next move with my
website I am gradually working towards
building a website where I can release
companion articles for each of the
videos I create and I'm building that
site with Squarespace
Squarespace allows you to create a
beautiful website or online store with
award-winning templates they have 24/7
customer service and they're intuitive
design platform makes it easy to create
the website you dreamed of you can make
your next move with Squarespace and
build a beautiful website by using the
code real engineering for 10% off your
next purchase Thank You Squarespace for
helping real engineering exist both here
on YouTube and on our beautiful new
website this month I was fortunate
enough to be able to get some help with
creating these videos from Moe Bock's
graphics thanks to sponsors like
Squarespace and my supporters on patreon
this allows me to create better videos
more often so if you'd like to support
the channel please check out Squarespace
or consider supporting real engineering
on patreon or even buying one of the new
real engineering t-shirts on dftba com
if you'd like to see more from me the
links to my Instagram Redis Facebook and
Twitter accounts are in the description
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you